قالت وزاره الدفاع التركيه ان عسكريين من
قواتها قتل اثرا انفجار عبوه الناسفه
يدويه الصنع في منطقه ما يسمى بعمليات
المخلب القفل الشمالي العراقي اتهمت وزاره
الدفاع في بيان صادر عنها تنظيمات وصفتها
بالارهابيه والانفصاليه بالوقوف وراء
الحادث في اشاره الى حزب العمال
الكردستاني واكدت الوزاره بان العسكريين
التركيين نقل الى المستشفى قبل ان يفارقه
الحياه بسبب الاصابه
كما ذكرت وزاره الدفاع التركيه ان قواتها
حيدت اربعه عناصر من من وصفتهم
بالارهابيين من حزب العمال الكردستاني
ووحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه شمال سوريا
وفي تغريده على تويتر نشرت لوزاره صورا
قالت انها للعمليه التي جاءت ردا على
اطلاق نار في منطقه عمليه غصن الزيتون
مؤكده ان عملياتها لمكافحه الارهاب ستستمر
بشكل حاسم وفعال على حد وصفها